un vrai temps de toussaint de la pluie
du vent et un risque accru d'accidents
pour ce week-end prolongé les forces de
l'ordre se sont montrés dans le
département dans les airs avec la
présence visible de l'hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie
ou sur les routes avec les voitures de
patrouille comme ici aux abords du péage
de saint-arnoult le week-end de la
toussaint
week-end traditionnellement fortement
accidentogène pourquoi parce que c'est
un long week-end donc il ya déjà
beaucoup de flux de chassé-croisé sur
les routes d'autre part je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne montre bien la
météo n'est pas clémente
donc il ya beaucoup plus de risques des
risques sont là donc il nous faut être
beaucoup plus présents et vigilante les
forces de l'ordre sont là évidemment je
le rappelle pour sanctionner quand il le
faut les conducteurs qui ont une
conduite dangereuse ou non conformes au
code de la route mais ils sont là aussi
pour se montrer et puis pour faire de la
prévention ce week-end les forces de
l'ordre ont sanctionné des excès de
vitesse mais également les comportements
dangereux comme les dépassements par la
droite et les distances de sécurité non
respectées
une voiture banalisée circulait parmi le
flot de véhicules depuis le début de
l'année 38 morts ont été enregistrés sur
les routes des yvelines avec un lourd
tribut à la fois essentiellement
d'ailleurs des des deux roues ce que 40%
des accidents son sens avec des deux
roues qui sont en cause ou victimes pour
cette opération qui a duré trois heures
23 infractions ont été relevées dont 13
concernaient des dépassements de vitesse
et pour les gendarmes le week end a été
positif dans leur zone d'intervention
aucun accident enregistré pendant ce
pont de la toussaint